jetzt geht es hier weiter mit dem
vierten corona steuer hilfe gesetzt er
will gleich die bundesfinanzminister als
erster zu reden es geht um
beispielsweise
sonderleistungen von arbeitgebern bis
3000 euro die steuerfrei bleiben sollen
es geht darum die home office pauschale
zu verlängern es geht darum die
sogenannte degressive abschreibung von
wirtschaftsgütern zu verlängern erhoffen
wir uns ein bisschen aufklärung was ihr
das im einzelnen und besonderen ist und
es geht darum die verlustverrechnung zu
verlängern also viele milliarden die
auch der wirtschaft helfen sollen durch
die korona pandemie besser raus zu
kommen beziehungsweise wieder fuß zu
fassen alles weitere jetzt vom
finanzminister
der titel des gesetzes sagt bereitet es
handle sich um steuerliche
hilfsmaßnahmen es ist nicht die von mir
prinzipiell gewünschte
unternehmenssteuerreform und es sind
auch nicht die unternehmenshilfen die
robert habeck und ich heute mittag
vorstellen werden es handelt sich um
steuerliche hilfsmaßnahmen aber dennoch
will ich denn natürlich eine maßnahme
hervorheben die wichtig ist die auch so
nicht geplant war und durchaus auch mit
bezug auf den richtigen beitrag des
kollegen meister in der
steuerpolitischen debatte von eben mit
den vorhaben und entscheidungen der
vorgängerregierung wäre die degressive
afa
anfang dieses jahres ausgelaufen in
einer situation wo wir tatsächlich
wirtschaftliches wachstum und
investitionen der privaten hand
stabilisieren müssen während das eine
falsche entscheidung gewesen um deshalb
sorgen wir mit diesem gesetzentwurf
dafür dass die degressive afa 2022
erhalten bleibt
und tatsächlich wollen wir darüber
hinaus noch eine sogenannte super
abschreibung machen deshalb habe ich
aber die spitzenverbände der deutschen
wirtschaft gefragt wollt ihr sie im jahr
wollt ihr sie haben angesichts von
lieferengpässen wollt ihr sie haben die
möglicherweise auch inflation verstärken
könnte wollt ihr sie in diesem jahr und
die spitzenverbände der deutschen
wirtschaft die bei mir im ministerium
waren haben unisono gesagt in diesem
jahr
2022 macht es keinen sinn und deshalb
werden wir uns dieses wichtige
instrument vorbehalten aber zu einem
zeitpunkt zu dem es wirklich wirksam ist
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ich will
einen letzten punkt anschließen weil
auch eben in der debatte von kollegen
meister gefragt worden ist ja wo sind
denn eure initiativen für
wirtschaftliches wachstum und ich
unterstreiche dass ich glaube ein
wichtiger beitrag zum wachstum ist dass
wir das planungs und genehmigungsrecht
in deutschland so beschleunigen dass
gute ideen überhaupt schnell umgesetzt
werden können das hilft auch schon beim
wachstum kostet aber nichts darüber
hinaus aber hat diese koalition 200
milliarden euro öffentliche mittel bis
2026 reserviert für energieeffizienz für
ladesäulen infrastruktur auch für fragen
der digitalisierung das ist unser
beitrag mit öffentlichen mitteln das
wachstum in deutschland zu stärken da
bewegen wir uns fiskalisch auch in einem
guten umfeld mit anderen
volkswirtschaften die es genauso machen
das halten wir für richtig das machen
andere genauso das sind erhebliche
mittel die das wachstum stärken und ich
frage mich wie kann man als cdu csu am
selben tag morgens im deutschen
bundestag maßnahmen für das wachstum
fördern und am mittag eine klage
vorstellen gegen den klima und
transformation spot der wachstumsstärke
das wort erhält für die cdu/csu-fraktion
der kollege olav gutting
der frau präsidentin werde kolleginnen
und kollegen wir haben es ja schon
gehört die bundesregierung muss zur
bekämpfung der folgen der korona
pandemie schon zu beginn dieser
legislaturperiode einiges tun allerdings
mir fehlt der glaube dass mit den jetzt
vorgesehenen
minimalen und halbherzigen korrekturen
tatsächlich die wirtschaftlichen
einschränkungen die wir haben gelindert
werden können
gezielte förderung von unternehmen zu
ihrer wirtschaftlichen erholung das hört
sich gut an und das benötigen wir auch
dringend aber was bedeutet das in ihrem
entwurf das bedeutete aufguss der
maßnahmen des zweiten corona steuer
hilfe gesetzes verlängerung der verlust
verrechnungsmöglichkeiten
verlängerung der degressiven afa für
bewegliche wirtschaftsgüter sowie die
verlängerung der steuerlichen
investitions fristen bewährte maßnahmen
sicher aber eben nicht ausreichend was
bringt ein unternehmen
auf zwei jahre ausgeweitet der verlust
rücktritt wir leben nur die pandemie
bedingten verluste mit weiteren
verlusten verrechnet werden dürfen wir
fordern sie daher auf
den ertrag steuerlichen verlust rückgrat
zeitraum auf mindestens drei jahre über
die krisenjahre 2020 bis 22 hinaus
dauerhaft auszuweiten und auch die höhe
der höchstbetrags grenzen beim verlust
rück trag auf 15 15 millionen euro
zumindest temporär zu erhöhen und dann
muss ich mal sagen sie mehren hier immer
um das hättet jedoch die letzten 16
jahre alles machen können jetzt muss man
auch seien die letzten 16 jahre hatten
wir eine durchschnittliche
inflationsrate von durchgängig weit
unter zwei prozent jetzt haben wir
sieben prozent jetzt stehen wir vor
einer stagnation aber sie gucken immer
nur in den rückspiegel und ich sage
ihnen damit fahren sie an die wand jetzt
ist die zeit zum handeln
jetzt brauchen wir mehr power jetzt
brauchen wir weniger zaghaftigkeit denn
nur so helfen sie denjenigen die
arbeitsplätze in diesem land schaffen
und erhalten und damit am ende auch den
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmern ja
es gibt kleine lichtblicke in diesem
gesetz die wir durchaus unterstützen wir
können zum beispiel die verlängerung der
förderung der steuerfreien zuschüsse zum
kurzarbeitergeld und die verlängerung
der bestehenden regelung zur home office
pauschale natürlich mit rat aber auch
hier bei der home office pauschale warum
schon wieder begrenzen entfristen sie
diese doch dass wir eine gute
signalwirkung für die arbeitnehmerinnen
und arbeitnehmer und unternehmen in
diesem land und nach
wortreichen ankündigungen
nach wortreichen ankündigungen
insbesondere des
bundesgesundheitsministers schaffen sie
jetzt einen steuerfreien corona bonus
für besondere leistungen des
pflegepersonals
mit dem gesetzestext allerdings
vorgenommen beschränkungen und ausnahmen
erreichen sie nicht den personenkreis
der tatsächlich zwei jahre lang
heldenhaftes geleistet hat die
regelungen für die steuerfreien bonus
zahlen von bis zu 3000 euro
sie sind zu kompliziert sie sind auf
einen zu kleinen kreis beschränkt und
sie sind insbesondere auch nicht mit den
öffentlichen arbeitgebern
abgesprochen die hier ja auch zahlungen
avisiert haben ich bin sehr dafür dass
wir alle pflegekräfte und alle
unterstützer für ihren einsatz
vernünftig honorieren das ist eine
selbstverständlichkeit aber wir müssen
auch an alle anderen steuerpflichtigen
denken die aufgrund der hohen inflation
aktuell großen belastungen ausgesetzt
sind und deshalb fordere ich sie auf
und das haben wir auch schon mehrmals
gehört dass wir bei der einkommenssteuer
eben jetzt nicht nur schönheits
operationen vornehmen sondern dass der
gesamte
einkommensteuertarif unverzüglich an
diese inflation angepasst wird mit der
erhöhung des grundfreibetrages ist es
nicht getan denn damit wird der tarif
gerade im eingangsbereich noch weiter
gestaucht das problem der kalten
progression wird dadurch noch verschärft
legen sie also diesen fünf
steuerprogression bericht jetzt vor
warten sie nicht bis zum herbst sondern
handeln sie jetzt jetzt haben wir die
belastungen und jetzt brauchen wir die
notwendigen tarifänderungen machen sie
die restaurierungs begünstigung und
endlich auch für kleine und für mittlere
unternehmen attraktiv wir haben hierzu
ja bereits vorschläge gemacht sie lagen
schon beim bundesfinanzminister scholz
auf dem tisch jetzt liegen sie bei ihnen
auf den tisch handeln sie endlich es ist
dringend notwendig diese thesaurierung
begünstigungen attraktiver zu machen und
ein weiterer punkt aus dem gesetz die
verlängerung der abgabefrist für die
steuererklärung
es ist natürlich richtig und gut aber
auch hier warum nur halbe kraft sie
wissen dass ohne gleichzeitige
verlängerung der offenlegungspflichten
für die jahresabschlüsse die sache nur
die hälfte wert ist warum bleiben sie
hier auf der hälfte stehen und gehen
nicht den ganzen schritt man kann
zusammenfassend fest halten
die maßnahmen in diesem gesetz sind über
um die wette zu simulieren sie bleiben
aber auf halbem weg stecken sie sind
viel kosmetik sie reichen bei weitem
nicht aus um das erklärte ziel dieses
gesetzentwurfes zu erreichen wie so oft
too little too late ich freue mich auf
die anhörung die bringt hoffentlich
weitere erkenntnisse
olav gutting ist für die
wir uns fraktionen mitglied im
finanzausschuss und unüberhörbar
unzufrieden mit einem gesetzentwurf den
die bundesregierung vorlegt das vierte
krone steuer hilfe gesetzt dass
nachteile ausgleichen soll die durch die
korona pandemie entstanden sind anders
lauten jetzt mutmaßlich die
argumentation von asamoah aus der
spd-fraktion und herren die
bundesregierung liegt heute neben dem
steuerentlastungsgesetz mit dem vierten
corona steuer hilfe gesetz ein weiteres
wichtiges reformpaket forum aktiv gegen
die auswirkungen der wirtschaftlichen
großwetterlage vorzugehen die inflation
voß sive inflation noch angetrieben
durch die spekulationsgewinne der
mineralölkonzerne sich verschärfende
lieferketten probleme uni
konjunkturellen folgen des furchtbaren
angriffskriegs von russland gegen die
ukraine lieber ermutigen das ist nicht
klein das ist nicht halbherzig
das fügt sich ein in ein gesamt
entlastungsvolumen von über 30
milliarden euro in diesem jahr und es
richtig gut und richtig viel
ich sprach über die gesamtmaßnahme in
diesem jahr die insgesamt greift ist
fügt sich ein und müssen wir zu hören so
in dieser lage ist es genau richtig
weiteres geld in die hand zu nehmen um
beschäftigte zu entlasten unternehmen zu
stützen und zielgerichtet zu investieren
wir wollen jobs wohlstand und existenzen
in deutschland sichern und zu einer
volkswirtschaftlichen stabilisierung
beitragen sowie ist derzeit so wie es
derzeit auch andere europäische staaten
machen damit wir einer möglichen
stagnation bestmöglich entgegen wirken
denn dieses szenario würde uns besser
würde uns deutlich mehr belasten als die
investitionen die wir jetzt noch zu
abwehr vornehmen können liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
die krisenfolgen stellen unser land auch
auf absehbare zeit vor große
herausforderungen bedürfen einer
abfederung daher wollen die
beschäftigten selbständigen unternehmen
mit steuererleichterungen
nicht mit der absolution jeglichen
akuten wohlstandsverlust verhindern zu
können dazu bedarf es einer
langfristigen dauerhaften strategie die
wir mit den maßnahmen 200 milliarden für
klima und energie einsparungen oster
paket und vielerlei mehr parallel
angehen sondern entsprechend mit dem
ansatz zu unterstützen
deshalb ist es für uns eine absolute
selbstverständlichkeit die herausragende
leistungen unserer pflegekräfte die sich
tagtäglich für unser gesundheitswesen
einsetzen dieser pandemie am limit
arbeiten und erlauben sie mir diese
bemerkung gestern von der union mit der
ablehnung der impfpflicht belohnt wurden
wenigstens finanziell zu würdigen mit
dem chor ohne pflege bonus der bis zu
einem betrag von 3000 euro steuerfrei
gestellt werden kann denn viele menschen
in krankenhäusern pflegeeinrichtungen
sehr gut gebrauchen können und auf der
grundlage unseres steuergesetzes
erhalten das ist unfassbar wichtig liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
stabilisierend wirkt sich auch unsere
anstrengungen für das kurzarbeitergeld
aus wir wollen die steuerfreien
arbeitgeberzuschüsse bis ende juni
verlängern damit geben wir unternehmen
planungssicherheit und sichern damit
auch millionen von jobs diese maßnahme
ist wichtig denn das modell der
kurzarbeit wird in der aktuell
angespannten konjunkturellen situation
wahrscheinlich noch in den kommenden
monaten bleiben wird ein sehr sehr
wichtiges instrument sein und wird
dringend gebraucht und das wissen wir
jetzt amtes koalition die mit
kolleginnen und kollegen
dann auch die regelung zum home office
gehen weiter unsere steuerzahlenden
können damit dieses jahr für jeden
kalendertag den sie von zu hause
arbeiten auch wenn sie kein eigenes
arbeitszimmer haben was er gelegentlich
der fall sein soll geltend machen wir
jetzt ampelkoalition wissen dass der
bedarf an mobilen und digitalen arbeiten
von zu hause während der korona pandemie
stark zugenommen hat oder auch in
zukunft für die beschäftigten und die
familien ein ganz wichtiges thema sein
wird deswegen ich glaub ich hab es heute
von den meister gehört müssen sie uns
nicht auffordern uns damit auch noch
einmal vertiefen zu beschäftigen lesen
sie sind koalitionsvertrag nach wir
werden das tun auch
für die unternehmen entfaltet das vierte
corinna steuer hilfe gesetz präzise
entlastungswirkungen dazu gehört als ein
überaus wirksames instrument die
verlängerte und erweiterte
verlustverrechnung die sich ab 2022 ford
folgende dauerhaft auf die unmittelbar
zwei vorangegangenen jahre erstrecken
sollen deutschland befindet sich mit
diesen maßnahmen unter anderem zur
verlustverrechnung als wirtschaftlichen
stabilisator auch im internationalen
umfeld ein guter gesellschaft und es
kombinieren wir mit der verlängerung der
steuerlichen investitions fristen für
reinvestitionen damit wir gerade die
liquidität von kleinen und mittleren
unternehmen stärken können
zu guter letzt möchte ich aber natürlich
auf die bereits heute mehrfach
angesprochene
möglichkeit auf die verlängerung der
degressiven abschreibung eingehen die
wir für das jahr 2022 vorsehen das trägt
auch zu einer schnellen refinanzierung
bei und schafft investitionsanreize ein
gutes stichwort für die im
koalitionsvertrag fest verankerte super
abschreibung oder auch investitions
prämie die in einen zeitraum nach 2022
kommen soll wir sehen darin große
potenziale um investitionen für die
digitale transformation und klimaschutz
zu mobilisieren und freuen uns heute
schon sehr auf die konzeptionelle
ausarbeitung des
bundesfinanzministeriums
die wird kolleginnen und kollegen zu
sehen wir bündeln mit dem vierten corner
steuer hilfe gesetz wirtschaftliche und
soziale maßnahmen und schaffen damit die
voraussetzung für eine echte
wirtschaftliche stabilisierung und
erholung auf diesen politischen kurs
können sich die menschen in deutschland
bei der ampel koalition verlassen auch
in schwierigen zeiten ich danke
casa maria ossowski die fraktion
verteidigt das vierte corona steuer
hilfe gesetz ein wortungetüm wie das
gelegentlich kennt aus dem bundestag
aber es soll tatsächlich für entlastung
sorgen bei bürgerinnen und bürgern vor
allem aber auch in der wirtschaft
nächster redner albrecht glaser aus der
redaktion
[Applaus]
herr präsident meine damen und herren
verehrter herr finanzminister herr
abgeordneter ich bin nicht herr
präsident
habe ich so verstand wenn ich so
gelaufen sein sollte habe ich
versprochen
wir beraten heute über das vierte ko das
steuergesetz einmal abgesehen von der
völlig 100 gramm absenkung der
umsatzsteuer entspannt sich 20 für ein
halbes jahr die 20 milliarden euro
mindereinnahmen des staates geführt hat
geht es nun um die verlängerung von
maßnahmen die den vorangegangenen carola
steuergesetzen angelegt sind nichts
neues nichts aufregendes und schon gar
nichts fortschrittliches
ihre botschaften der minister wie sie
heute mittag verkünden würden in der
öffentlichkeit wäre schön wenn man sie
heute morgen im parlament gehabt hätten
wo wir doch so schön beieinander sind
die steuerliche freistellung von
sonderzahlungen an die beschäftigten die
bereich der krankenversorgung und der
pflege bis zu einem betrag von 3.000 die
verleihungen der steuerfreistellung von
zuschüssen zum kurzarbeitergeld um sechs
monate bis ende 22 und die verlängerung
der gewährung der home office tauschen
um ein jahr bis zum 31 dezember 22 zur
förderung unternehmen sollen die
regelungen der degressiven abschreibung
um ein jahr längert werden ein erhöhter
verlängerte verlust rückfragen
verlängerte fristen für steuerliche
vergünstigung bei investitionen nach §
6b und 7 g des einkommenssteuergesetzes
sollen eben was eingeräumt werden
grundsätzlich stehen wir diesen
maßnahmen positiv gegenüber zu
kritisieren sind jedoch die inhaltlichen
mängeln der regelung die zögerliche art
der umsetzung in der gesetzesbegründung
ist vom konsequenten maßnahmen die rede
und der absicht planungssicherheit zu
schaffen genau dieses leistet wofür doch
nicht warum wird erst im april 22 über
die steuerfreiheit von kurzarbeitergeld
entschieden dass in den vergangenen
monaten bereits gezahlt worden ist warum
beraten wir erst heute über steuerliche
förderung von corona sonderzahlungen die
bereits im letzten jahr geleistet worden
sind dazu kommt die unbegründete
vielleicht auf verfassungswidrige
ungleichbehandlung von ähnlichen
sachverhalten während die bereits
bestehende steuerfreiheit für boni bis
zu 1500 euro allen arbeitnehmern zugute
kam gegen die hier vorgeschlagene
steuerfreiheit für weitere boni bis 3000
euro nur für eine bestimmte berufsgruppe
als ob beschäftigte in anderen berufen
nicht auch den besonderen belastungen
der korona krise ausgesetzt waren die
verlängerung der home office pauschal
ist nicht ausreichend weder in der höhe
von nur 600 euro noch in ihrer
zeitlichen erstrecken die arbeitswelt
hat sich geändert das wurde schon
angedeutet und deshalb ist eine
weitreichende reform für dieses thema
vermögen wir haben die afc bereits im
dezember 20 die modernisierung der
antiquiert antiquierten regelung zum
häuslichen arbeitszimmer erfordert
drucksache 23 725 bei der hilfe
unternehmen ist ebenfalls mangelnden
wirksamkeit zu kritisieren die
unternehmen dürfen ihre verluste von
zwei jahre zurück tragen ja auch dass es
angedeutet worden was aber nützt ein
verlust druck trat von heute in zwei
corona jahre die davor liegen in denen
gewinne gar nicht wirtschaftlich sind
worden sind vielleicht verluste
entstanden sind
wirksame maßnahmen
meine sehr verehrten damen herren sehen
anders aus und wie sie aussehen könnten
haben wir ebenfalls in unserem anderer
vom april 20 zum ersten kroner
steuergesetz in der beschriebenen druck
sei bereits gefordert dazu fordern wir
temporäre abschaffen der
mindestbesteuerung ich höre es nicht
wäre eines der wichtigsten im falle von
nicht ausgeglichen verlusten
hochaktuelles thema ein verlust rückgang
mit verlängerten zeitraum auch bei der
gewerbesteuer ich höre davon nichts wäre
außerordentlich wichtig und aussetzung
der zinsschranke voller berücksichtigung
der zinsausgaben gerade bei unternehmen
die beispielsweise durch hilfe stellt
die müssen nicht anschließen dann auch
die chance haben müssen sie ihre
darlehenszinsen abzusetzen was ja wie
sie wissen durch eine sperr regelung
verhindern würde der bundesrat hat in
seiner jüngsten stellungnahme ähnliche
maßnahmen gefordert wie auch viele
fachleute die das genauso sehen wie wir
das steuerliche durch die sie bitte zum
schluss werde was nun frau präsidentin
das steuerliche durch vorstellung der
großen koalition in den letzten jahren
hat mit der bundestagswahl im letzten
jahr so kein ende gefunden
vielmehr bewegt sich die ampel koalition
auf gleichem gesetzgeberischen niveau
von kommen
heinrich glaser für die afg fraktion mit
weiter um das vierte krone steuer hilfe
gesetze und jetzt wird albrecht glaser
noch gebeten noch seine maske wieder
aufzusetzen nachdem er schon einen
kleinen stockfehler bei der begrüßung
der bundestagspräsident vize präsidentin
hatte nächste rednerin katharina becker
fraktion bündnis 90/die grünen
finanzpolitische sprecherin mit
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen
kollegen liebe bürgerinnen und bürger
wir verpflichten uns dem wohle aller
bürgerinnen und bürger zu dienen
so haben wir das als koalition
miteinander vereinbart und es ist
überhaupt nicht halbherzig lieberherr
gutting sondern sehr ganz herzlich was
wir hier tun entlastungspaket 1
entlastungspaket 2 das corona steuer
hilfe gesetzt wir verlängern auch gute
überbrückungshilfen und heute mittag
kommen noch mal neue wirtschaftshilfen
es ist sehr ganz herzlich dass wir hier
tun und wir haben das wurde aller
bürgerinnen und bürger im blick
und heute geht es eben um steuerliche
aspekte und das ist vielleicht nicht das
begeisterte wort aber es betrifft doch
fast alle menschen in diesem lande
diejenigen die 15 millionen die letztes
jahr im home-office bahn da eine gewisse
steuerliche entlastung zu ermöglichen
sich jetzt hineinzuversetzen wie haben
die denn gelebt zeitlich auch zu
entfristen
wir machen die steuererklärung 's
fristen entlasten wir auch für alle
diejenigen die steuererklärungen abgeben
nicht nur für die die beraten sind auch
natürlich für diejenige für über eine
million körperschaftsteuer flüchtlingen
wichtige aber eben auch für alle die
steuererklärung abgeben müssen und das
ist eine große entlastung in diesen
zeiten wo so viel belastung auf einen
bürgerinnen bürgern lastet
und mit dem pflege bonus
endlich klatschen wir nicht nur sondern
geben ganz gezielt den ungefähr 250.000
pflegenden in krankenhäusern und den
über eine millionen tätigen in
pflegeeinrichtungen endlich den bonus
zumindest ansatzweise das kann man ja
gar nicht beziffern was sie geleistet
haben aber auch dass steuerfall zu
stellen dafür ist ein steuergesetz
einfach da und wichtig und davon
profitieren millionen von menschen und
nun auch die unternehmen
wir brauchen konjunktur in diesem land
und da ist ist einfach wichtig dass wir
die investitionen vorziehen können das
hat der herr der herr von der spd ja
schon gesagt entschuldigung passat so es
ist einfach wichtig das trifft vor allen
dingen die kleinen und mittelständischen
unternehmen und das ist ganz wunderbar
denn diejenigen leiden gerade ganz
besonders wir haben die
verlustverrechnung endlich ermöglichen
wir sie das hätte die vorgängerregierung
längst schon machen können dann hätte
man das auch vorziehen können auf die
folgejahre aber jetzt kommt es und zwar
langfristig und das ist sehr sehr gut
und dann haben wir noch die degressive
afa ich glaube es ein offenes geheimnis
wir hatten uns gewünscht und durch die
ukraine krise und die fossile
abhängigkeit ist das noch dringlicher
dass wir investitionen steuern steuern
steuern dass wir da hingehen können dass
wir eben anreize für energie
unabhängigkeit für klimaschutz und
digitalisierung und resilienz machen
können dass er arbeiten wir dann eben
jetzt das ist mein wermutstropfen diese
degressive afa die zwar konjunktur an
krieg und investitionen aber nicht
gezielt alles in warum ist dieses gesetz
aber ein sehr sehr gutes gesetz ein
gesetz unser ganz herzigen politik zum
wohle aller bürgerinnen und bürger
herzlichen dank
[Applaus]
nächste rednerin in dieser debatte ist
ingenieur wisla die partei vorsitzende
der links fraktion und mitglied im
finanzausschuss
und das wort erhält für die linke die
kollegin janine wissler
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
beim vorliegenden gesetzentwurf geht es
um die verlängerung von
steuervergünstigungen im zuge der korona
pandemie vorweg bei vielen steuerlichen
vergünstigungen bezweifeln wir
grundsätzlich ob es so ein geeignetes
mittel ist um diejenigen zu entlasten
die es am nötigsten brauchen denn von
steuerlichen entlastungen nach dem
gießkannenprinzip profitieren auch viele
die es nicht leuchten und deswegen
halten wir eine direkte förderung
grundsätzlich für sinnvoller nur ein
beispiel
trotz corona haben die 30 dax konzerne
im vergangenen jahr die höchsten gewinne
aller zeiten verbucht einige haben
dividenden ausgeschüttet obwohl sie
gleichzeitig kurzarbeitergeld und
anspruch genommen haben warum sollen
denn auch diese konzerne die chance
erhalten verluste in 20 22 und 23 mit
gewinnen aus 20 21 zu verrechnen das
meine damen und herren halten wir für
falsch mehr noch es gibt unternehmen die
sich trotz sonne bewegen wie dumm und
dusselig verdient haben dazu gehören
natürlich zuvorderst die digitalen
handels plattformen wie amazon und co
und wer hilfspakete für von die academy
geschädigte und hätten schnürt der
sollte gleichzeitig auch die apps
profite der krisengewinnler abschöpfen
quasi als einen fairen ausgleich
zwischen den verschiedenen kursen die
unterschiedlich betroffen war und das
gilt natürlich auch gerade für die
energie und mineralölkonzerne die sich
angesichts steigender taschen die
angesichts steigender preise die taschen
voll machen auf kosten der verbraucher
und hier hat die eu kommission jüngst
noch mal festgestellt ausdrücklich dass
ein abschöpfen solcher extraprofite mit
eu recht vereinbar sind ich frage sie
warum machen wir das denn nicht wie in
italien und übersteuern die
krisengewinner stärker meine damen und
herren da in dem gesetz ja auch der
geplante corona pflege bonus steuer
freigestellt wird dazu auch einige worte
der bonus wurde lange verschleppt und
eine milliarde reicht bei weitem nicht
nicht für alle pflegekräfte und schon
gar nicht für die vielen anderen
beschäftigten im gesundheitswesen die
ebenfalls stark belastet waren und sind
die rettungsdienste die ambulante pflege
und versorgung die hebammen alle
menschen im gesundheitswesen haben unter
schwierigsten bedingungen
großartiges geleistet und sie haben
leider nicht von der steuerfreiheit weil
sie den den bonus erst gar nicht
bekommen werden angesichts des
pflegenotstands im gesundheitswesen
hilft kein einmaliges trostpflaster was
wir brauchen sind gute
arbeitsbedingungen dauerhaft höhere
löhne und nicht der einmalige bringen
der bundeskanzler hat eine zeitenwende
ausgerufen über nacht 100 milliarden
euro für die bundeswehr angekündigt wir
lieben diese aufrüstung ab und wir
lehnen auch die in dieser woche
beschlossene bewaffnung von drohnen ab
meine damen und herren die korona
pandemie hätte doch ein weckruf sein
müssen für soziale gerechtigkeit und für
das gesundheitssystem
dafür brauchen wir dreistellige
milliardenbeträge
und das hat ihr gesetzentwurf enthält
einige sinnvolle regelung aber er tastet
die dramatische soziale schieflage in
diesem land leider überhaupt nicht an
vielen dank
[Applaus]
janine wissler war das auf sie folgt nun
markus herbrand der finanzpolitische
sprecher der fdp fraktion ihren der
debatte zum vierten corona steuer hilfe
gesetz über das die abgeordneten nach
dieser debatte dann die das überweisen
werden in die entsprechenden ausschüsse
mit
verzeihung für das verzeihung sehr
geehrte frau präsidentin die wir
kolleginnen und kollegen das gros der
steuer hilfe gesetz teilt vier ganz
wichtige impulse für den weg und die
wege aus der krise einige weitere
entlastungen und einige verlängerungen
von regelungen aus dem corona show hilfe
gesetzen 1 bis 3 ganz wichtig aus
unserer sicht für vor allem auch kleine
und mittelständische unternehmen die
erweiterung des verlust rückschlags das
ist das instrument für die versorgung
mit liquidität bei unternehmen und auch
die verlängerung der degressiven
abschreibung halten wir für richtig das
ist ein
enormer investitionsanreiz der gute
zeichen für die zukunft setzten dann es
gibt auch weitere gute sachen für
bürgerinnen und bürger der korona bonus
ist bereits erläutert worden und auch
die verlängerung der steuerfreiheit für
das kurzarbeitergeld sicherlich sehr gut
bei der home office pauschale da gibt es
die befristung bis zum 31.12 unsere
fraktion kann sich da sehr gut
vorstellen dass wir das auch entfristen
wir werden damit sicherlich in
gespräche mit den partnern aus der ampel
regierung eintreten das ist die neue
realität
das home office insofern müssen wir da
auch unsere gesetzlichen regelungen dran
passen
abschließend wegen meiner langen rede
zeit möchte ich noch auf die
fristverlängerung für steuerberater
eingehen oder für steuererklärungen
eingehen ja auch ich bin aufpassen ich
teile die auch das und das wird
vermutlich nicht ausreichend seien denn
dafür sind einfach zu viele neue
aufgaben auf den berufsstand zuge kommen
nächstes jahr wird oder dieses jahr wenn
es noch die vielen vielen grund
steuererklärungen sein wir werden
darüber reden müssen und das leidige
thema veröffentlichung von
jahresabschlüssen sie wissen das ganz
genau herr kollege der 31 zwölfte ist
eine von der eu gesetzte frist
diesbezüglich die kann man nicht
verlängern diese frist sie ist nicht
verlängerbar diese frist das hat im
übrigen herr kollege auch etwas mit
gläubigerschutz zu tun und genau deshalb
gibt es diese fristen insofern ich will
ja nicht in der zeitung lesen cdu ist
gegen gläubigerschutz also das war sie
sehen sicherlich auch nicht lesen wir
werden machen was rechtlich möglich ist
und was im übrigen vertretbar ist
herzlichen dank
herr abgeordneter gauland würden sie
bitte auch eine maske aufsetzen im
plenarsaal
als nächstes erhält das wort für die
cdu/csu-fraktion der kollege fritz
künstler
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
meine damen und herren erlauben sie mir
vorher noch eine anmerkung zu der
aussage des herrn bundesfinanzministers
bezogen auf die aussage von herrn doktor
meister von heute morgen sie verweisen
auf einen vermeintlichen widerspruch
zwischen der forderung des kollegen
meisters mehr für wirtschaftswachstum zu
tun und dass wir heute gegen den
nachtragshaushalt 20 21 klagen darüber
werde ich mit ihnen gar nicht
diskutieren das wäre mir ein anderer
stelle bestimmt noch tun wie erklären
sie sich eigentlich den widerspruch
persönlich dass sie in karlsruhe für die
vollständige abschaffung des
solidaritätszuschlags zeitig diese
abschaffung überhaupt im
koalitionsvertrag steht ich finde den
widerspruch eklatanter dass sie ihr
eigenes handeln nicht daran aus leiten
lassen was sie auch selber eigentlich
wollen wir haben heute zwei gesetze
beraten wo es um entlastungen geht und
das steuerentlastungsgesetz und das
corona steuer hilfe gesetz 4 wo wir
wiederhole ich mich von heute morgen und
kollegen zwar auch schon gesagt und zum
ziel ja eigentlich sind es geht um
stabilität sei visierung von wirtschaft
wir wollen die eigenkapitalbasis der
unternehmen stärken wir wollen mehr
liquidität in die unternehmen bringt
also von daher einigkeit im ziel und
jetzt müssen wir uns gegenseitig prüfen
ob die antworten die wir auf diese frage
geben auch ausreichend ist und da haben
wir doch schon erhebliche bedenken und
die haben wir auch dargelegt und ich
werde sie auch kleinere darin von daher
lassen sie uns in den wettstreit
eingehen das beste die beste lösung zu
finden damit wir gemeinsam dieses ziel
erreichen können was wir erreichen
wollen und ich erwähne auch noch mal war
das immer von den linken oft kommt
dieses thema wir würden unternehmer
irgend entlasten werden lasten
unternehmen und jede
volkswirtschaftliche studie beweist
ihnen dass die entlastung von
unternehmen letztendlich zur sicherung
von beschäftigung führt also zu einer
höheren beschäftigung letztendlich auch
zu höheren löhnen und auch zu mehr
wachstum das die in allen von daher ist
es ganz konkrete leistung für die
arbeitnehmerinnen arbeitnehmern wenn wir
unternehmen entlasten und von da sind da
ja auch massnahmen vorgesehen in der
krone in dem kronach steuergesetz 4 der
finanzminister hat auch vorangestellt
dass das noch nicht der
unternehmenssteuerreform entwurf ist das
werfe ich ihm auch gar nicht vor wir
haben das lange genug mit unserem
koalitionspartner versuchte einiges zu
erreichen wir haben als cdu csu fraktion
bereits im november 2009 10 einem papier
beschlossen markus herbrand wird sich
erinnern zur modernisierung des
deutschen unternehmens steuerrecht das
sehr inhaltsgleich mit dem fdp antrag
war den ich leider lange nicht mehr
gesehen habe aber wir sind uns auch da
eigentlich einig und von daher ist das
thema verluste adressiert und es ist gut
auch da wollten wir mehr aber der
spd-finanzminister scholz hat ja damals
das verhindern von da ist es richtig
dass die beträge noch mal erhöht werden
von da ist es richtig den rücktritt
zeitraum auf zwei jahre dauerhaft zu
verlängern wir müssen nur zur kenntnis
nehmen wenn wir das für die veranlagung
jahre 2022 bis 2023 machen dass wir die
verluste genau in die jahre zurück
tragen sollen wo wir die korona bedingt
verluste in den gesellschaften jahren in
2020 2021 und das ist das problem
grundsätzlich gut zwei jahre aber das
führt oft völlig in diesem moment und
von da ist es eine scheinlösung und
deshalb unser vorschlag dass wir auf
jeden fall temporär auf drei jahre gehen
um genau das zu erreichen was sie ja
auch eigentlich erreichen wollen und was
völlig unter den tisch gefallen ist im
rahmen der verlustverrechnung verluste
sind ja latente steueransprüche an den
start von da ist es klug wenn man diese
liquidität fließend macht für die
unternehmen ist die sogenannte
mindestbesteuerung das ist sehr
technisch aber es ist morgens so dass
sie verluste nicht unbegrenzt vortragen
können also nicht vollständig verrechnen
können mit gewinnen die hoffentlich nach
der korona pandemie nach der jetzigen
ukraine krise entstehen können sie
können nur eine million euro unbegrenzt
verrechnen darüber nur 60 prozent und
ich würde vorschlagen dass wir die
korona verluste die entstanden sind
nutzen dafür dass wir die
mindestbesteuerung für diese zeit
aussetzen ich glaube dass wir ein großer
beitrag für die unternehmen wenn wir
hier bei der verlustverrechnung nach
vorne kommen und dazu gehört natürlich
auch die verbesserung der
abschreibungsbedingungen wir sind sehr
für die degressive abfragen ich begrüße
dass er ausdrücklich dass das kommt wenn
schon die super abschreibung oder turbo
abschreibung nicht kommen aber ein
unterschied will ich doch auch
herausarbeiten die kollegin weg hat ja
sehr darauf abgehoben dass es bei den
super abschreibung um gewisse
investitionen geht in klimaschutz
bezeichnen digitalisierung die
abgrenzungsfragen ist sehr schwer und
herr minister die spitze die
spitzenverbände werden ihnen auch gesagt
haben dass sie sich eigentlich wünschen
dass ähnlich oder genau wie bei der
degressiven abschreibung alle
investitionen also alle wirtschaftsgüter
besser abgeschrieben werden können und
von daher sollten wir dann da auch noch
mal gemeinsam diskutiert letzter punkt
die zeit läuft auch mir weg
fristverlängerung herr kollege hermann
ich bin ich ja sehr dankbar und der
bundesrat hat ja heute glaube ich auch
in all ihrer seiner weisheit einstimmig
entschieden dass das nicht ausreichend
ist das hier gemacht wird und die länder
sind ja für den steuervollzug zuständig
von da an ist die ampel kurz unglaublich
gut beraten diese vorschläge zu
übernehmen aber nur ein hinweis zum
bundesamt für justiz die ja nicht die
frist verlängert haben aber die
aufgriffsrecht verlängert haben auf den
siebten märz und ich finde es den
unternehmen die offenlegen müssen schon
nicht fair gegenüber wenn der flippten
märz die frist abläuft auch ein knopf
gedrückt wird und dann die androhung von
zwangsgeldern raus geht in dieser
situation da kann man auch anders mit
umgehen und ich hab auch die erwartung
an das bundesamt für justiz in zukunft
damit anders umzugehen herzlichen dank
fritz künstler war so ist unter anderem
mitglied im bundesfinanz gremium das
unter anderen die parlamentarische
kontrolle über das schulden wesen des
bundes auch und in denen die hessel haus
spricht jetzt und ist wie ihre vorredner
mitglied im finanzausschuss
allerdings für die spd fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
die pandemie setzt die menschen in
deutschland mehr belastungen aus den wir
seit ihrem beginn entschieden
entgegenwirken
insbesondere
insbesondere die steuerpolitischen
maßnahmen sorgen für konkrete
entlastungen für die bürgerinnen und
bürger und die unternehmen mit dem nun
vierten corona steuer hilfe gesetz in
den letzten zwei jahren führen wir den
weg der gezielten steuerlichen
entlastung fort
mit der verlängerung der abgabefrist für
die steuererklärung in 2020 2021 und
2022 reagieren wir auf die belastungen
der steuerpflichtigen und der
steuerberatenden berufe
steuerberaterin und steuerberater haben
einen deutlich erhöhten beratungs und
unterstützungsbedarf weil bei ihm in der
pandemie zusätzliche aufgaben
hinzugekommen sind besonders die ballung
der abgabefrist für steuererklärungen
die bearbeitung von wirtschaftshilfen
und jahresabschlüsse stellen eine echte
herausforderung für die kanzleien da die
starke arbeitsbelastung haben wir
erkannt und in den vergangenen jahren
die steuerlichen abgabefristen immer
wieder verlängert so haben wir
regelmäßig für zeitliche entlastung
gesorgt
nun legen wir ein konzept vor das
bereits jetzt für die
veranlagungszeiträume
2021 und 2022
fristverlängerungen für die abgabe der
jahressteuererklärung
vorsieht wir denken voraus denn die
frühzeitige regelung der abgabefrist ein
bis ins jahr 2024 hinein schafft
planungssicherheit für steuerpflichtige
kanzleien und die verwaltung
wir haben bereits in der vergangenheit
darauf wert gelegt dass auch die
menschen entlastet werden wie ihre
steuererklärung ohne beratung erstellen
deshalb sind auch für sie verlängerungen
bei den abgabefristen für die
steuererklärung vorgesehen
das vierte ko ohne steuer hilfe gesetz
enthält darüber hinaus eine reihe von
maßnahmen die arbeitnehmerinnen und
arbeitnehmer im besonderen unterstützen
die kurzarbeit hat millionen
arbeitsplätze durch die pandemie
gerettet passend zur verlängerung der
maßnahme bis ende juni werden auch die
arbeitgeber zuschüsse zum
kurzarbeitergeld bis ende juni von der
steuer befreit von dieser maßnahme
profitieren insbesondere die
beschäftigten der besonders hart
betroffenen branchen etwa im
veranstaltungs- und gastronomiebereich
diese unterstützung ist notwendig denn
ihre einkommen werden dadurch
stabilisiert während ihre jobs gesichert
werden
die pandemien hat uns die
verletzlichkeit unseres
gesundheitswesens vor augen geführt die
pflegekräfte in deutschland erbringen
tag für tag eine herausragende leistung
über das bisherige maß hinaus hat die
pandemie die bedingungen in den
krankenhäusern und pflegeeinrichtungen
noch anspruchsvoller werden lassen die
belastung ist außerordentlich hoch wie
im koalitionsvertrag angekündigt stellen
wir geld bereit um in bestimmten
einrichtungen ein pflege bonus bis zu
3000 euro durch die arbeitgeber von der
steuer zu befreien auch bei bezug von
grundsicherung bleibt der pflege bonus
unangetastet so stellen wir sicher dass
bei den beschäftigten möglichst viel von
dem geld auch ankommt
die post office pauschale ist ein kind
der pandemie viele hätten sich nicht
vorstellen können so oft wie jetzt in
den eigenen vier wänden zu arbeiten bis
zu 600 euro können auch in diesem jahr
als werbungskosten geltend gemacht
werden unabhängig davon ob man ein
arbeitszimmer hat oder beispielsweise in
der küche arbeitet
mit den massnahmen zugunsten von
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmern und
unternehmen zeigt sich die von der spd
geführte ampere regierung als
verlässliche partnerin in der krise wir
stabilisieren die wirtschaft und stärken
die konjunktur das signal das von unsere
maßnahmen ausgeht lautet die sicherung
der arbeitsplätze und die entlastung der
bürgerinnen und bürger sind uns wichtig
auf unsere unterstützung kann man sich
verlassen
den hessen haus hat jetzt zum schluss
auch noch mal die bestehende regelung
zur home office pauschale angesprochen
die noch mal um ein jahr verlängert
werden soll fünf euro pro tag können
angesetzt werden wenn eben arbeiter oder
selbstständige von zu hause aus arbeiten
letzte rednerin in dieser debatte ist
sandra deetzer für bündnis 90 die grünen
sehr verehrte frau präsidentin werte
kolleginnen und kollegen zu gruner ist
nicht vorbei und die pandemie
beschränkten einschränkungen stellen
natürlich eine vielzahl von bürgerinnen
und bürger von unternehmen vor große
belastungen und an der stelle haben wir
einfach die große hoffnung dass dieses
coroner steuer hilfe gesetz dazu
beiträgt diese lasten so gering wie
möglich zu machen
bezogen auf das haushaltspolitische
volumen sticht eine der maßnahmen die
degressive abschreibung ganz konkret ins
auge die jährlichen steuer
mindereinnahmen scherz des bmf auf knapp
zehn milliarden euro in den vergangenen
den nächsten vier jahren und das ist
natürlich schon eine stolze summe
und jetzt herr künstler und sie völlig
recht es steht nicht im
koalitionsvertrag
aber das zeigt glaube ich sehr sehr gut
ist wir in der lage waren auf akute
situationen auch zu reagieren und nicht
nur im koalitionsvertrag in
arbeitsprogramm abarbeiten was wir uns
mal aufgeschrieben haben und das ist er
am wo punkt als im contra und sage ich
als jemand der zusammen mit seiner
fraktion gar nicht unbedingt der größte
fan war dieser degressiven afa deswegen
freuen wir uns auch herr bundesminister
sie haben es angesprochen wenn wir uns
gemeinsam dann weiter nochmal
mittelfristig auf den weg machen und
nach der verlängerung jetzt der
degressiven afa und die investitions
prämie die sogenannte super vornehmen
die wir eben im koalitionsvertrag
vereinbart haben
diese abschreibung soll genau das können
was die dixie warf er jetzt noch nicht
kann nämlich so soll diese ökologische
diese lenkungswirkung entfalten die wir
insbesondere auf ökologische
investitionen und auf investitionen in
digitalisierung haben wollen
insbesondere zum beispiel in meiner
region stuttgart meinem wahlkreis warten
viele darauf dass wir es noch einfacher
machen einfach in energieeffiziente
anlagen maschinen und produkte
interessieren zu können und genau das
haben wir vor denn eins darf uns
natürlich auf keinen fall passieren dass
weder corona noch jetzt dieser grausame
angriffskrieg putins auf die ukraine die
investitionstätigkeit in deutschland
erleben lässt
wir werden
zusammen mit unternehmen mit privaten
sehr sehr viel geld brauchen um
lieferketten zu diversifizieren um den
umbau hin zu einer klimaneutralen
gesellschaft und auch wirtschaft
natürlich zu gestalten entwicklung
digitaler geschäftsmodelle
infrastrukturen weiterqualifizierung all
das werden wir von staatlicher seite
unterstützen damit eben da sind gerade
die degressive afa und die super afa in
der perspektive in baustein damit
unternehmen und ihren beschäftigten auf
diesem langen weg die puste eben nicht
ausgeht herzlichen dank
[Applaus]